la collégiale notre dame ont été moins
de la course
en juin prochain les pelotons feront ne
boucle autour de mantes-la-jolie un
circuit dans le vexin en soit le pas le
parcours il n'est pas d'une difficulté
extraordinaire par contre on change
énormément de rythme et c'est ça je
trouve qu'il donne à ce côté technique à
ce circuit des boucles de 21 km 104 km
pour les femmes 253 pour les hommes et
plusieurs traversées de la scène un
circuit qui devrait sourire aux
sprinteurs je pense qu'il manque une
réelle difficulté pour faire vraiment la
différence est que
malheureusement avec
vu qu'il ya pas de quotas dans les
équipes et qu'on se retrouve parfois
avec des équipes comme la française des
jeux où ils sont 26 coureurs c'est très
facile de contrôler sur un circuit comme
celui là et pour réchapper un sprint il
va falloir
une course de mouvement j'aurais sans
doute aimé un peu plus dur mais bon
je pense qu'il ya il ya ce qu'il faut
quand même après c'est les coureurs qui
font la course
c'est vrai que ces dernières années il
ya eu plus dur mais il ya aussi moins
dur donc voilà je pense qu'on peut comme
comme comme souvent on peut avoir un
grand sprinteur qui peut passer et où
alors on préférera pour les puncheurs
les championnats de france reviennent en
ile-de-france vingt ans après montlhéry
en 97
une nouvelle compétition cycliste pour
le département c'est un très beau sport
c'est un sport praticable par tout le
monde et à tout âge
et puis c'est un sport qui est un sport
de plein air symbolique de ce
département 8 maillot bleu blanc rouge
seront attribués du 28 juin au 1er
juillet verdict dans deux mois